[SPEAKER_00]: Excellency Minister of Development and Planning, Excellency President Taub, Excellency Zaka Afuna, Hanan, GIT economists, ladies and gentlemen, .
[SPEAKER_00]: Let me start by saying thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you to the African Development Bank, to President Taub, to Kevin, for such a warm welcome here to Abidjan.
[SPEAKER_00]: We are delighted to be part of the EU and also in UNDP in this conference.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is true, as we have heard from all panelists before, that we are living in a moment of real change.
[SPEAKER_00]: The certainties that shaped international cooperation for decades are being tested.
[SPEAKER_00]: Power is more dispersed, all alliances are shifting, and the rules of trade, investment, and development finance are being rewritten in real time and high uncertainty.
[SPEAKER_00]: The conflict in the Middle East is the latest in a series of global supply chain shocks
[SPEAKER_00]: that have benefited economic growth and even fragmentation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Earlier this month, the OECD revised down its global growth projections to 2.8% in 2026.
[SPEAKER_00]: The impacts are expected to be particularly severe for developing countries which have less fiscal space and also face higher costs for energy and food.
[SPEAKER_00]: The impacts are real for millions of people in this region.
[SPEAKER_00]: More food insecurity, rising poverty,
[SPEAKER_00]: In this new context, trade, investments, and development cooperation are not set by the genders.
[SPEAKER_00]: There are actually different pieces of the same puzzle.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this building economies that create jobs, reduce dependency on external resources, and strengthen resilience to shocks.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, the impacts on development finance are particularly significant.
[SPEAKER_00]: We must recognize that in some parts they are severe, direct,
[SPEAKER_00]: and very distinct, especially in Sub-Saharan Africa where OGA accounts for relatively high shares of GDP in some countries.
[SPEAKER_00]: In 2025, official development assistance fell by 23%, the sharpest drop since the OECD began extracting its OGA in 1960, a decline of nearly $1 billion.
[SPEAKER_00]: We project a further fall this year,
[SPEAKER_00]: And for South-Saharan Africa and these developed countries, projected levels in 2020 states are even lower since the thousands.
[SPEAKER_00]: Multilateral challenges are not expected to fill completely this gap.
[SPEAKER_00]: So for many pioneers, age is no longer a reliable growing source of violence.
[SPEAKER_00]: The reality is quite sovereign, and instead of making us be in the possession of despair, it should really sharpen our resolve.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we must find the best way to protect and prioritize ODA and make better use of all the forms of development science, ensuring that all of these laws maximize their development potential.
[SPEAKER_00]: Business as usual is no longer possible, nor wanted.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we are channels and also channels to innovate to make a moment.
[SPEAKER_00]: So my ask of all of you today is to let us, to show us what innovation and change look like.
[SPEAKER_00]: for Africa and in Africa's parents, so that future allocations of concession and finance in this multi-polar world can work better and harder for Africa and not just around it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Africa's history is not a place of shrinking age, it is really one of extraordinary potential.
[SPEAKER_00]: You have just heard my Secretary-General Corman speak about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: The continent holds a large share of the critical minerals that the world needs for its clean energy transition and for its digital transformation.
[SPEAKER_00]: It has the world's youngest population and the fastest growing workforce.
[SPEAKER_00]: And through the African continent's free trade area, it is building one of the largest and most impressive markets on Earth, single market center.
[SPEAKER_00]: Trade can be converted into resilience with all of this potential that could happen
[SPEAKER_00]: for those productive economies that Hannah was just mentioning before, and it created those jobs as invaluable, diversifying partnerships, and reducing dependency on one single market for a dollar.
[SPEAKER_00]: The trade policy must also keep developments front and center.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is about people.
[SPEAKER_00]: It is always about people.
[SPEAKER_00]: The DeJoy OECD WTO Food Trade Initiative shows what's possible.
[SPEAKER_00]: In 2024 alone, it mobilized $51 billion
[SPEAKER_00]: nearly a fifth of all development assistance to help countries participate in and benefit from trade.
[SPEAKER_00]: So turning potential into consolidated agency, as President Tam mentioned in his initial statement, also demands new ways of working and learning together.
[SPEAKER_00]: So in this spirit, the OECD posted here with support from Kenan and the team from the African Development Line,
[SPEAKER_00]: the Global Network of Chief Economists of International Development Agencies and Finance Institutions, a space where the world's development institutions share ideas, evidence, and challenge each other's assumptions, and really listen to how they're coping with this multi-colour world, and how do you actually do in terms of global partnership development policy and practice.
[SPEAKER_00]: And yesterday, we held this annual meeting,
[SPEAKER_00]: as part of the AAC and the day before that, and even more important milestone, if you allow me, is with that one who met with the African City Economist Network too, and you allow for that conversation to happen.
[SPEAKER_00]: That exchange was energetic, it was really candid, it was full of practical ideas on how to take the solutions forward into a really common spirit of peer exchange.
[SPEAKER_00]: Networks like this bring international and regional national expertise
[SPEAKER_00]: to learn the most pressing challenges for the men that are facing.
[SPEAKER_00]: Not to prescribe answers, but to bring evidence, tools, and partnership to a conversation that Africa is needed.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we are privileged to be part of this conversation that Africa is needing, and we are retaining pride in partnering with you as we move along, and we are here to see how we can best support you in that ambition.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you